this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up guys michael here with another
philosophical reaction to the only show
on tv with a giant incest space baby as
a recurring character obviously we're
talking about rick and morty season five
now we've already unpacked some of the
philosophical themes from this season in
previous videos from the history of war
to the morals of eco-terrorism to the
all-encompassing logic of capitalism but
one theme that stood out to me
throughout the season was morty's quest
to find some kind of identity or meaning
in his life outside of being his dick
grandpa's sidekick because the idea of
personal identity has been a common
topic for philosophers across the
centuries so let's see if i can squeeze
some philosophical wisdom out of a
season that ends with a monologue from a
character named mr poopy butthole
coincidentally my childhood nickname
welcome to this edition of a philosopher
reacts to rick and morty season five who
is morty and spoilers ahead for the
latest rick and morty and some very old
philosophy books but before we get into
it i want to give a shout out to this
week's sponsor surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn
helps you secure your data by using
uncrackable encryption in the most
secure vpn protocols plus it's fast and
easy to use one of my favorite things
about surfshark is that it lets me binge
content from around the world that i
otherwise wouldn't be able to access i
really hate when i hear about some cool
new comedy special from the uk but can't
actually watch it but with surfsharkvpn
the internet can't figure out where i'm
located that means i can simply use one
of their servers to log into bbc iplayer
and let the absurdist comedy wash over
me you can also unlock the 15 largest
netflix libraries around the world that
way when you're traveling abroad you can
keep up with your favorite reality shows
from back home about hot people on
islands it's a content connoisseur's
dream one subscription will allow you to
protect all your favorite devices
whether it's a laptop android amazon
fire stick and even your playstation or
xbox and there are apps for all your
favorites too like chrome and firefox
surfsharkvpn is fast easy to install and
jam packed with features if you use the
link in the description and use the
promo code wisecrack you can get
surfsharkvpn for 83 off its normal
annual price plus three extra months for
free
so go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show let's start with morty's
first big non-jessica crush of the
season like many impressionable young
men morty gets into a new cause to
impress a girl or a super heroine he
likes i got kind of a positive vibe good
i was putting one out i i really like
you holy sh not unlike the time i became
a vegetarian in college just to try to
make my crush like me
she didn't but i did stay vegetarian for
three years so you win some you lose
some but enough about me let's see how
meeting a sentient amalgam of elements
helps morty find his identity there's a
huge forest fire like 200 miles from
here this is amazing planeteen is bound
to be there mom i i need the credit card
to buy a train ticket absolutely not mom
this is the biggest wildfire of the year
you're not going i'm not last time i
checked this wasn't russia it's not
russia jerry my heart is broken and i
deserve to let it they have a whole
separate mission in this episode you can
suck my bigger tit adios words
i don't want you getting hurt please
think this i don't want to think i want
to see a girl i like talk about a hot
foot
this wildfire on ice
come here little buddy come on come on
come on i gotcha okay so this is one of
the first times in the season and series
we see morty try to find identity
outside of his lap dog relationship with
rick hoping to impress his new crush
planet tina he rescues a rabbit from a
forest fire like a good environmentalist
warrior in this moment morty is at least
at the surface level um finding a new
identity and purpose and a cause that's
bigger than himself and he's seemingly
willing to risk burning to death in a
forest fire to commit to this cause now
apologies in advance for being a broken
record but you might be aware that one
of my favorite philosophers is soren
kierkegaard um feel free to illegally
pirate the book i wrote on him and this
19th century danish sad boy has a great
quote about finding meaning he writes
what matters is to find my purpose the
crucial thing is to find a truth which
is truth for me to find the idea for
which i am willing to live and die in a
way that foreshadows the existentialist
that would come onto the scene a century
later kierkegaard is getting at the idea
that
true identity is something that comes
from deciding on a purpose that will
orient our lives and we see that in this
episode as morty's crush-inspired belief
in a cause leads him to take action he
rallies a sort of enthusiasm that we
rarely see in our little
semi-professional masturbator this idea
of finding truth and identity and some
purpose outside of yourself becomes a
huge theme for the 20th century
existentialist it also later becomes a
core theme of the work of actually still
a live philosopher elon bed jew who
thinks that finding an idea to live for
is what creates human identity and
subjectivity but as we'll find out
sometimes this type of enthusiasm can go
a little too far let's see how that
plays out all of you get out of there
you're killing the planet your people
didn't get the votes leave or i'll have
you arrested you people who should be
arrested gutting the land poisoning the
air your children breathe can't you see
what you're doing easy for you to say
you can live how you want we need the
jobs let's go boys i really see both
sides here we'll get them next time
there's no time left can't you hear the
earth screaming you feel me better tina
stop
okay i no longer see both sides
just the ferning people reflecting in
his eyes
okay um so this is when living for a
cause gets a little
sketchy now planetean well not a human
has an identity that's completely tied
to the cause of environmentalism and
this isn't inherently a bad thing it's
probably a good thing until you know it
it leads her to murder a bunch of
probably innocent people and we've seen
this in history when people form their
identities around
nationalism fascism and other very not
good causes to jump back to the 18th
century
philosopher emmanuel kant was aware of
the temptation to turn good-natured
enthusiasm into a more dangerous
fanaticism now kant drew distinction
between religious fanaticism which has
more to do with the individual's
relationship to god and moral fanaticism
in which someone projects their own
beliefs onto the world as a whole
philosopher and theorist alberto toscano
describes kant's view of fanaticism like
this
the moral fanatic is a subject who in
refusing to submit himself to the
universality of duty can easily turn
into a well-meaning murderer for kant
fanaticism is always a transgression of
the limits of human reason well-meaning
murderer you say like uh like murdering
a bunch of dudes going to work because
you think it's morally right to do so
now what toscano is saying here is that
when you become fanatical about your
so-called life's purpose
you run the risk of doing
things to aid that purpose
and continuation of moral fanaticism
helps us understand how in the course of
an episode planet tina can go from
putting out forest fires to lighting up
human beings also we did a video about
how maybe she was right so
check that out if you haven't and of
course the whole murder thing
complicates morty's romantic feelings
for planet tina leading to a sort of
crisis of identity
morty are you all right
she's gone mom she's gone i loved her so
much i know you did honey
i'm just so sad mommy's here
[Music]
it's nice to have your mom comfort you
it's weird to have your mom come for you
and right behind you there's a picture
of a woman with giant breasts but
philosophers have been talking about
love since philosophy became a thing one
of plato's text symposium is basically a
transcript of a bunch of dudes getting
faced while giving speeches about the
nature of love in this text they talk
about eros which is a type of love that
can make someone transcend their old
identity and achieve new heights via the
passion and purpose love has given them
it's like how prince harry used to be a
guy who dressed up as a nazi for funsies
but then he married meghan markle and we
all decided that he was the good royal
okay it's not quite like that but you
get the point now aristotle who
when you think about it is sort of like
the morty to plato's rick also thought
love was super important to identity he
argued that in love you find meaning and
purpose through putting the needs of
another above your own in a sense you
find a new identity in this love and
more specifically in your love and care
for another person and hollande jew
thinks that love is one of the ideas
that's worth living for and that it can
even help humans become immortal what's
more love can give us a sense of courage
and passion that's so profound that it
can transform our very identity
also a lon bet dude is an old french man
who's been married like
10 or 20 times so
i guess take take all this with a grain
of salt now we see all of this and
morty's romance with planet tina and
then sadly we see this all ripped away
from him shining a light on how much
he'd been lacking a real sense of love
and identity now finding identity and
love is risky because it's dependent on
another person and the other person can
always leave or do murder
[Music]
so if you can't find identity in your
love for a murderous sentient amalgam
where can you find it well for many
folks and especially people during
things like the world cup it can be
found in national identity now morty's
own sense of national identity becomes
clear during the kind of so-so
thanksgiving episode when he struggles
to understand a revised history of his
beloved nation so after those aliens
discovered america we went into
hibernation leaving us the technology we
use to lead the free world that and also
to do stuff like slavery i always
thought we were more special than that
like we invented everything and did
everything and that's why we own
everything no i i i don't know what to
feel feel thankful morty feel thankful
okay so
this right here makes me think of the
trial of socrates um spoiler alert he
lost they killed him i guess i guess he
needed oj's lawyers now you probably
know that one of the charges leveled
against socrates was the corruption of
the youth basically the political elite
in athens got pissed that socrates was
encouraging their sons to think
critically and examine things for
themselves
rather than just believing whatever
their toga clad dads told them to that
wasn't socrates only charge because they
also put him on trial for atheism but
this isn't the type of atheism that rick
espouses throughout the entire run of
the show it's a specific type of
disbelief a disbelief in the gods of the
athenian state and these gods weren't
like actual deities they represented
values in society for example if france
had gods they would be liberty justice
and fraternity
and daydream
and if america had gods they'd be
freedom judge judy and the song closing
time by the band semi-sonic
time for you to go home to the places
you will be from
but in morty's case we see that one of
the foundational beliefs of the church
of the bald eagle is american
exceptionalism the idea that america is
a special and well exceptional place a
place that's deserving of its wealth and
abundance and a key part of this
narrative is the foundational story of
early american pilgrims and native
peoples vibing out over a turkey dinner
that had absolutely no undertones of
colonial violence after realizing that
this narrative is untrue and also that
aliens actually fought off evil turkeys
to help start america morty is left like
one of socrates eager students
questioning the dominant values of the
state this then seems to destabilize
both his personal identity and his
relationship to a larger national
identity now i really like this example
because it's a reminder that as far back
as socrates personal and social identity
were already intertwined it also
reinforces the reality that thinking
philosophically has always had a social
and political element because it
involves questioning dominant social
values okay so now morty has failed to
find identity and an activist cause and
love and innovation so where else might
this sad young lad find meaning and
purpose how about the most magical thing
of all friendship stop those poor boys
did you hear that that's gonna stick
[Music]
damn just like jackie chan i guess that
makes me chris tucker right i guess
that's really gross
holy did you see that i mean you blinded
a guy with puke oh it was insane give me
dap am i doing it right did i give you a
dap yet look at us we got out and not
just from the asylum but from rick you
get to say what an adventure is now
nicknames are so cool um but morty's
story right here is getting pretty sad
he's on such a mission this season to
find some type of identity and he's
really looking for it in all the wrong
places
here he's trying to find identity in a
friendship
with a guy he met through an accidental
hand portal so you know just normal
stuff now while nick turns out to be
not a good dude morty isn't wrong to
look for meaning and friendship and
famous smartypants of the ancient world
aristotle agreed for him true friendship
is an important and valuable thing which
can lead to real happiness for all
parties involved and this friendship
looks like two virtuous people who
genuinely want what's good for each
other while morty might have genuine
intentions here nick
not so much aristotle was aware that
most friendships aren't true and good
the bad ones are friendships of pleasure
where you're just friends with someone
because it makes you feel good or
usefulness where you're friends with
someone because they can get you cool
stuff and here nick who is a bad dude is
using friendship with morty for his own
personal gain and it ends how bad
friendships always do with someone
having to cut their own hand off via a
moving train and then cauterizing the
wound with a fancy jet pack so for all
his trials and tribulations morty still
seems pretty philosophically ruthless
but there is one morty who seems to
confidently find a new identity
unfortunately it's evil morty every
version of us has spent every version of
all of our lives in one infinite crib
built around an infinite baby and i'm
leaving it that's what makes me evil
being sick of him if you've ever been
sick of him you've been evil too
rick did you really leave the crows for
me or did you come back because they
dumped you
there you go kid now you're evil morty
too sooner or later we all are now
finally we have a morty that seems
confident in his identity and it was
using the purpose given by this identity
to make things happen sadly that
identity is rooted in being evil and the
purpose he's living for involves
exploiting and murdering tons of other
mortys and ricks along the way but it's
interesting to see how evil morty's
motivations and new sense of self sound
kind of reasonable and i think this has
to do with something that hegel talked
about called recognition for him this
was a way to talk about the development
of consciousness now later marx picked
up this idea to talk about exploitation
taking place in the factory and today
recognition is still one of the key
concepts used by contemporary critical
theorists like axelhonda the extremely
tldr version of this concept is that we
develop into fully formed cells by being
recognized as a self by another self
this helps us develop both identities as
individuals and also social identities
as we are recognized by others as human
beings
sometimes however
misrecognition happens in which certain
people are seen not as subjects but as
objects and this leads to things like
evil morty and the ricks violently
exploiting the labor of less valuable
mortys it's actually my new favorite boy
band evil morty and the ricks and for
some contemporary theorists like hanith
recognition is a central aspect of
democracy in which we must have a shared
sense of recognition and cooperation to
create a society truly guided by well
all of us and while evil morty is
definitely evil he also got there due to
frustration with the fundamental
misrecognition between rix and morty's
so his plan to break through the central
finite curve is born of a desire to live
in a world that isn't fundamentally
defined by this type of misrecognition
in which ricks are never going to offer
mutual recognition to mortys this
doesn't make it cool that evil morty is
exploiting the labor of other mortys we
have a video on this too if you if you
want to get into it but it's at least an
example of one version of morty
reckoning with the way that rick's
fundamental misrecognition has trapped
him in the identity of always forgiving
rick's cosmic selfishness okay so that's
basically the end of morty's journey
this season will he find a meaningful
identity in the future
probably not um yeah no he's definitely
not going to but before you lose all
hope let's check out the after credit
scene of the finale but i guess things
went downhill from there started
isolating myself from amy and used to
tell her everything i was feeling but
then i guess i stopped cause i wanted
her to love who she thought i was not
who i felt myself becoming ever think
about how horrified the people we love
would be if they found out who we truly
are so we just dig ourselves deeper into
our lies every day
ultimately hurting the only people brave
enough to love us
wish i didn't do that
wish i was brave enough to love them
back i don't know maybe you should try
it we don't have as much time as we
think oh we
oh wow um
i i really can't believe that one of the
most emotionally impactful things i've
seen on tv in years is this monologue
from mr poopy butthole
but it's amazing and makes me think of
this famous line where hegel says that
the owl of minerva flies at dusk which
is his way of saying that philosophy
only understands things through
hindsight and i think this epilogue to
the season can help us look back at
what's been happening all along
our buddy mr poopy butthole is sad and
alone precisely because of an inability
to find his identity in love and
specifically a fear of sharing true
mutual recognition with his wife he's
basically admitting that he's chosen
self-deception and isolation
over sharing loving recognition because
of this he's clearly miserable if we use
mr poopy butthole-colored glasses to
look back on the whole season we see how
morty has also been caught up in these
serious self-deception that's holding
him back from finding love and
meaningful identity
honestly like i'm gonna be thinking
about this scene for a while and it's
unreal that this is coming out of the
mouth of a character called once again
mr poopy butthole
but what do you guys think is morty
doomed to a life of unhappiness can we
hopefully learn from his horrible
mistakes and will mr booby butthole get
his wife back
let us know in the comments thanks as
always to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our
podcast also let me know if there are
any other shows or movies that weren't
the old philosophical once-over hit that
subscribe button like you're tossing a
molotov cocktail at a to
congressperson's house and don't forget
to ring that bell and as always thanks
for watching later
to the only show on tv with the giant
incest space baby as a returning
character i said returning character
that was really weird
i'm dying i think